there were many compelling
moments sprinkled throughout the hours
and hours of presentations
during donald trump's second impeachment
trial
one of the most interesting came during
the portion of the trial
when senators can send up questions to
be answered by either or
both the house impeachment managers and
donald trump's
defense lawyers bernie sanders sent up
a really simple question and it
completely
set off attorney michael van der veen
one of donald trump's attorneys
and the question was simply did trump
lie about winning the election
is it true what the house manager said
which is that for months donald trump
wrongly
claimed to have won the election bernie
asked it
van der veen went nuts asking who asked
that
and a titillating exchange took place so
we'll take a look the question is read
by the clerk but it's bernie's question
that bernie sent up
and when van der veen asks who asked
that you will hear bernie in the
background say i did
and then all hell breaks loose and
counsel for the former
president recognized for two and a half
minutes
of course the clerk will read the
question again
the house prosecutors have stated over
and over again
that president trump was perpetrating a
big lie
when he repeatedly claimed that the
election was stolen from him
and that he actually won the election by
a landslide
are the prosecutors right when they
claim that trump was telling a big lie
or in your judgment did trump actually
win the election
the council for the former president
have two and a half minutes
my judgment who asked that
my judgment's here relevant in this
proceeding it absolutely
is what's supposed to happen here
is the article of impeachment is
be in order
the senators under the rules cannot
challenge the
content of the response the council will
continue
may have the question read again please
the house prosecutors have stated over
and over
again that president trump was
perpetrating a big lie when he
repeatedly claimed
that the election was stolen from him
and that he actually won the election by
a landslide
are the prosecutors right when they
claim that trump was telling
a big lie or in your judgment did trump
actually win the election
in my judgment it's irrelevant to the
question before this body
what's relevant in this impeachment
article
is were mr trump's words
insightful to the point of violence
and riot that's the charge
that's the question and the answer is
no so michael van der veen really not
liking
bernie's question but it actually got
van der veen
to say something fascinating you heard
van der veen there say
the only issue here is whether what
trump
said was an incitement to the riots
many of the republicans who voted not
guilty including mitch mcconnell as we
just covered
said trump did incite the riots but
that's not the question
so i i this is not trivial understand
how disjointed and pathetic this all is
trump's own lawyer when asked by bernie
was trump lying when he said he won the
election says
the only only only thing being
adjudicated here
is did donald trump incite the riots
mitch mcconnell comes in and says not
guilty
yes trump incited the riots yes what
trump did is morally indefensible
yes what trump did was foreseeable in
leading to what it led to
but that's not the issue the issue is
simply whether we can convict a
president that's already out of office
even trump's own lawyer there says
the only question is whether trump
incited the riot
and if yes then presumably you vote
guilty but mitch votes not guilty and
then says trump didn't cite the riot
but it's a procedural explanation for
why
i voted not guilty they aren't even in
agreement
about what this trial was about
now to deal with the other part there
are people who wrote to me
and said it was funny to see van der
veen triggered by bernie's question
but that factual question isn't actually
relevant to these proceedings now
strictly speaking
it is true that the lawyer's opinion
about a matter
uh like that isn't relevant to whether
trump is or isn't guilty
but remember that this isn't a court of
law this is an impeachment court
in the u.s senate and adhering to the
truth
is relevant much of the case that van
der veen
and trump's other lawyers made didn't
adhere to the truth so
merely and and remember it's not a
criminal proceeding senators can ask
anything
as a check on the validity and
comprehension of these lawyers
it was interesting to hear bernie asked
such a basic factual question it's
also relevant that in the entire context
in which trump's actions are being
interpreted in terms of his inciting the
riot
it would be different if in reality
trump had won
trump may i i'm not saying that the
moral consideration about the riot would
necessarily be different that would be
for each senator to to think about and
judge
and for us if the election really had
been stolen from
trump i think there are tens of millions
of people
including many on the left who would see
the entire thing differently
so um an interesting moment for sure
and van der veen just i mean like
instantly hair trigger
set off by bernie's question let me know
your thoughts
now that the impeachment trial is done
what's next
i'll talk later about well one of the
things that should be immediate
is coveted relief but send me your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at
deepakman
let's face it most healthy snacks don't
taste
that good they don't fill you up they
don't really satisfy your cravings
which is why you should check out monk
pack today's sponsor
monk pack keto nut and seed bars taste
like your favorite delicious sweet
snacks
but each bar has less than one gram of
sugar only
two to three grams of net carbs and
they're just 150 calories these are
perfect
for a keto or low carb diet or
anybody who wants to cut back on sugar
flavors include caramel sea salt sea
salt dark chocolate
and peanut butter dark chocolate that's
my go-to i
love the monk pack keto nut and seed
bars because they're just a good balance
of sweet and salty
soft and chewy and a great crunch from
the nuts and seeds
and they will give you all of your money
back if you don't love them as much as i
do
go to monkpack.com the link is down
below and they'll give you
20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman